C'est une ville meurtrie, un théâtre de
ruines.
Comme si la vie s'était soudainement
arrêtée,
Bash tanka est un dédale de gravats,
une cité fantôme dans les décombres des
fragments de vie.
Les Ukrainiens sont parvenus à
reprendre
ville après quatre jours d'occupation
par l'armée russe,
qui a tout rasé.
-Ils tiraient sur les maisons
torturées.
Ce n'est pas tout. Ce n'est pas humain.
Un peuple qui dit être frère,
un peuple qui ment au monde entier et
qui ment à son propre peuple.
Il n'y a pas de pardon.
Ensuite, que Dieu accorde sa miséricorde
au royaume.
On a trop d'eau
-à 500 km de là,
à Kharkiv, la deuxième ville du pays.
Les pompiers continuent de fouiller
les décombres de l'administration
régionale.
24 corps ont déjà été retrouvés dans ce
bâtiment dévasté par
un bombardement russe au début de la
guerre.
Le bilan n'est toujours pas définitif.
Que la situation à Kharkiv reste la
même.
Nous sommes frappés par des roquettes,
des groupes de saboteurs, tente d'entrer
dans la
ville pour démolir les infrastructures,
mais nous
les combattons et nous les vaincrons.
Dans ce quartier en périphérie
de Kharkiv et bombardés presque chaque
jour,
Sales Tikka, situé près de la ligne de
front,
est un champ de bataille,
-notant
-que
ses habitants survivent terrés dans ses
ses caves, au milieu de rares affaires.
Beaucoup sont malades et n'ont nulle
part où aller.
-Il y a donc maintenant des bénévoles
nous apportent
de la nourriture sous les bombes.
Si nous n'avons pas d'eau, nous devons
aller à
une source à un kilomètre sous les
frappes.
Il n'y a pas de lumière.
Vous voyez si êtes à
-de rares habitants s'aventurent encore dans le
le quartier. Au milieu d'immeubles
dévastés.